[Musique]
bonjour à tous je suis content de vous
retrouver soyez les bienvenus à ce
rendez vous d'information d'antenne 2 de
la mi-journée vous connaissez les
horaires 13h 13h45 vous restez si vous
pouvez vous rester si vous le voulez
nous avons légèrement modifié la
structure de cette émission je veux pas
vous faire détails parce que ce serait
un peu long et on a beaucoup de choses à
vous dire
sachez qu'en gros voici les étapes
principales l'actualité en début
d'émission tous les jours le plus tôt
possible le plus complètement possible
avec patricia charnolé que vous
connaissez bien pour l'avoir vu souvent
en thème de faire des commentaires
politiques ensuite nous parlerons de
votre vie quotidienne
on m'a assez vaste comme sujet vous
dirai raison la vie quotidienne ça va de
votre mal au dos à nos enfants on est
mercredi c'est pas une mauvaise idée
d'en parler aujourd'hui ou à vos dettes
cet été y ait si bien nous verrons ça
aussi et également des vedettes bien
toutes vos vedettes nous les inviterons
au fur et à mesure il faut savoir aussi
que si vous êtes des habitués d'antenne
de midi vous vous retrouvez aujourd'hui
dans un espace différent et guerre ce
nouvel espace d'information sachet qui
servira à toute la famille informations
ante m2 c'est à dire pour nous à 13h à
18h30 20h 23h pas à télématin et matin
c'est dans un autre appartement ailleurs
tiens à propos dès le matin ça fait
penser à quelque chose
si vous regardez cette émission depuis
un an et demi nous sommes deux vieilles
connaissances
dans le cas contraire et c'est la
majorité bah vous ne l'avez jamais vu
alors je vais faire comme les élèves en
début d'année je vais me présenter
selon découper une petite feuille de
papier on était son nom en haut à gauche
alors mon prénom c'est william et mon
nom c'est l'énergie y au début qui à la
fin mon âge 39 ans et je crois que là
vous savez l'essentiel voici maintenant
les titres de votre journal
la rencontre bar giscard il est fort à
parier qu'il sera question d'élections
au président c'est une rencontre très
médiatisé vous en doutez c'est peut-être
pas un hasard
la participation en conseil des
ministres deux ordonnances présenté ce
matin par edouard balladur objectif vous
le savez intéresser les salariés aux
résultats de l'entreprise et puis la
savoie au tableau michel barnier que
vous voyez là qui sait qu'il sera avec
nous tout à l'heure va plancher cet
après-midi devant les membres du comité
international olympique pour défendre la
candidature d'albertville et pour les
jeux d'hiver
lorsqu un soutien de poids plus apporté
jacques chirac puisqu'il est à lausanne
afghanistan afghanistan si régime
soviétique le pays alors seront ils
remplacés ou passer d'une question qui
vient en tout cas ça indique peut-être
une modification de la stratégie de
l'union soviétique dans ce pays depuis
l'intervention 1979 et puis pour ce
premier jour une bonne surprise ou un
événement c'est comme vous voulez on
n'ose pas trop dire événement ce sera
j'espère une bonne surprise la présence
d'une équipe d'antenne 2 dans le studio
d'enregistrement du prochain album de
julien clerc et il sera notre invité
tout à l'heure lui aussi vous expliquera
comment et combien l'ordinateur est
devenu un partenaire indispensable
oui mais rassurez-vous le talent c'est
toujours les hommes là il n'y a aucun
doute là-dessus avec nous également le
docteur julien cohen solal je vous
disais c'est mercredi pourquoi pas
parler des enfants et du langage des
tout petits
d'ailleurs est-ce qu'il faut dire
langage on verra et enfin une
exclusivité
encore une en plus de celle de julien
clerc dans son studio la présence d'euro
disney disney oui comme l'autre c'est le
neveu ce monsieur qui a une cinquantaine
d'années c'est pas un bambin dont il ne
veut pourriez croire non non c'est le
neveu du grand walt qu'il est venu avec
des images c'est à dire les images du
dernier film basile
voilà pour le sommaire de cette édition
du 15 octobre
[Musique]